Pope Pius II was born Enea Silvio Piccolomini
near Siena, Italy in 1405, one of 18 children.
His family was part of the Italian aristocracy,
but they had fallen into poverty.
Once the future Pope was old enough, he went
to university and then began work as a teacher,
before becoming a secretary to Cardinal Domenico
Capranica in 1431.
He was later a follower of the Antipope Felix
V and was excommunicated for siding with a
man who went against the real Pope’s wishes.
Back then, the future Pope Pius II was part
of a group that is today known as the Renaissance
humanists.
He also fathered illegitimate children and
wrote erotic literature and obscene poetry.
Shortly after one of his illegitimate children
died, he joined the court of the Emperor Frederick
III as an imperial poet and private secretary
to the Emperor in 1442.
Two years later, the future Pope wrote The
Tale of Two Lovers.
Historians believe he might have written other
books and manuscripts with similar subject
matter, and in addition to the novel, a romantic
comedy has been attributed to him.
Whatever the case, The Tale of Two Lovers
is about a man who falls in love with a married
woman.
The two exchange letters, and their correspondence
makes up a bulk of the book, making it one
of the first examples of an epistolary novel.
As an example of the type of content within
the book, Pius wrote:
Now Sigismund, though advanced in years, was
quick to passion; he took great pleasure in
the company of women, and loved feminine caresses.
Indeed he liked nothing better than the presence
of great ladies.
So when he saw these, he leaped from his horse,
and they received him with outstretched hands.
Then, turning to his companions, he said:
‘Have you ever seen women like these: For
my part, I cannot say whether their faces
are human or angelic.
Surely they are from heaven.’
In his later years, Pius II looked back on
his past with some regret.
Writing to a friend, he said,
I know what you will say: why, how strait-laced
Aeneas is; now he writes to me of chastity
from Vienna, but in Neustadt be spoke otherwise.
I don’t deny it, dearest John, but time
slips away, day by day; we are older, the
day of our death draws near, and now we must
consider not how to live, but how to die…
For me, John, I have sinned enough, and too
much.
Now I know myself, and may it not be too late.
For now I am forty, and the day of salvation,
the time for repentance is at hand…
Pius II attempted to suppress the Tale of
Two Lovers, not wanting the transgressions
of his pre-Pope days to catch up with him,
but the book proved to be too popular.
However, he was a prolific writer, and many
of his other writings eclipsed the Tale of
Two Lovers, at least in the eyes of the church.
His Commentaries was published by a distant
relative long after his death, along with
his autobiography written in the third person.
In addition, he wrote about historical events
as well as political, religious, and ethical
issues of his time, which have proven to be
invaluable resources about the time period
in which he lived.
If you’re wondering how someone with a background
frowned upon within the Catholic church made
it all the way to its highest office, Pius
II made his way from sinner to Pontificate
through a remarkably rapid set of promotions.
These were partially the result of the fact
that he was well liked among his peers and
also genuinely excelled at tasks given to
him, despite his perhaps less than ideal morals
by the church’s standards.
His rapid rise began after being made a representative
in Frankfurt.
After breaking off his friendship with the
Antipope in 1445, he was absolved of his excommunication.
In 1446, he was ordained as a priest.
He then helped to resolve issues between the
German princes and the Pope, and for his efforts
was made a bishop in 1447.
Thanks partially to a recommendation from
his former employer, Emperor Frederick III,
a little over a decade after the removal of
his excommunication, he was made a cardinal.
This leads us to his next jump, to Pope.
According to Pius II himself, after the death
of his predecessor, the man who was the favourite
for the position of Pope was a cardinal named
Guillaume d’Estouteville who was of exceptional
character.
However, Pius II felt that he’d do a better
job than d’Estouteville in the position
of Pope.
He also felt that it would be an easy enough
task to improve upon his own personal character
to match d’Estouteville’s, which would
be necessary if he was chosen.
He set about attempting to convince the other
cardinals of these things and was elected
unanimously in a second ballot, taking up
the position of Pope in 1458.
While he was Pope, his attention was focused
on developing a crusade against the Turks,
who had invaded Constantinople.
He even went so far as to implore King Mehmet
II to convert from Islam to Christianity.
This effort ultimately failed.
As morale waned with the crusaders, Pope Pius
II traveled to join them, but ended up falling
ill and dying shortly thereafter on August,
14, 1464.
Because he spent most of his time as Pope
waging war against the Turks, little of note
was accomplished during
his papacy.